what's up gamers it's me peter pi oh
should i say what's up fellow
minecrafters
that's right i am no longer afraid to
say it
i'm a minecrafter grab your pickaxe and
smash like with it if you agree
i don't know if you guys remember but
long long long ago there used to be
shows on this channel
meme review pew news aka rolling
response to gay dumbledore controversy
why leave yourself in the comments below
but they're all gone now it's minecraft
and nothing else my subreddit lawyer has
turned into minecraft
and i'm okay with it i just like how
everyone is on board my views have
literally gone
up and if you are not on board then go
play fortnite
loser that's right i said it alright
let's get into the minecraft memes
why is all this gold you might ask sven
well it's for an old friend
i wasn't planning for it i mean i did pl
i planned for it that's so nice
i just thought it would be a nice ending
what else am i going to do with it
he'll come back oh my god that's amazing
that's so cute
nate tyrix very epic kawaii
spencer wait didn't i review this meme
already 2017 fortnite beats pubg
popularity 2018 apex fails to be
fortnite in popularity 2019.
fine i'll do it myself everyone is
arguing now
oh yeah minecraft is really popular now
but it's not thanks to pewdiepie
people have been playing it all the time
oh yeah so all of a sudden
it goes from steady popular to more pop
popular
[Music]
please okay oh but other people ever
played it hold
all the time yes so good for them idiots
i'm the biggest minecraft channel
get it in uh we're gonna get you out of
here buddy
i freaking sorry a side note i gotta say
every
minecrafter you whatever they've been
very so susceptible
to the nine-year-old so i appreciate
anyway we're gonna get you out of here
buddy like everyone kept saying i
literally just had to stand on a
platform
and make him not sit down it doesn't
work if you're too far away
okay i'm not a dummy dumb i may be dummy
dum dum but i'm not a dummy though poor
jurgen
i mean sven wait
what felix burnt down jurgens tree i'll
plant a tree for your jurgen
oh god no launch minecraft
i need to plant it right now i'm not
addicted i'm just i
like i i'm fixing the meme hurry sven we
must plan three
very quick okay christ is averted next
meme
very epic very emotional very good video
yeah that was amazing good job brad for
adding as well it's bad
hello because i yelled york
i'm such an idiot i'm so dumb i am a
dummy dumb i take it back
find expect can we talk about can we
talk about the fact that sven
actually swam to a freaking hole in the
ground
despite i spend a lot of time down there
looking for him he doesn't show an
edit but i took a long time and
so many mobs went down and just died
sven however
persevered and he lived and that's why
he's my dog
my number one bro i mean number one and
one
when your girl disappeared for a second
where did marzia go
i'm free finally loki that church looks
like it's built in minecraft
when your horse disappears for a second
this is so sad or forever i've seen the
chat voice
don't look at me when i speak to look at
me when i speak to you
confused screaming listen if you guys
think i mean
to watersheep you have to understand
that he's playing a character
he pretends to act innocent and
civilized
when in reality if you knew what went
inside watersheep's brain
oh my god the amount of vox articles
my god oh you're so cute sven
can't wait to show you to jurgen wow
it's a freaking iceberg jurgen would
love this place
i'm discovering so much jurgen i wish i
could bring you along in my adventures
but don't worry i will always tell you
stories
this is so sweet oh here it is
rare biking boat burials it's a viking
boat as well
unearthed in first discovery of its kind
in 50 years archaeologists say
hold up a horse and a dog in sweden
there it is i wish it said viking in the
title
that's so perfect what is happening here
literally the same day
sven disappeared i couldn't find edgar
for like half an hour
i'm like god damn it what is happening
martin said he's probably thinking about
other girls pewdiepie alright tomorrow i
have to finish the one
i've legit done this while falling
asleep because it suits me
what an exciting episode pewdiepie sven
jurgen
i don't know where this is from but it's
very accurate
bros squad fab nine-year-olds gamers
minecrafty minecraftian bros okay i
don't know don't murder the turtles
oh okay i can harvest there's scoots
what the frick is a scoot
it's cute it's cute oh my god what a
dumb name
i painted jurgen took like ages don't
let it die in you one jurgen
damn you're gonna look in hella fiery
man can i go back into the nether and
find jurgen is that possible
if i can still retrieve him then let me
know the jurgen one come back no
no this is not your
no stop saying that pierce doesn't know
anything about the game
pewds house oh my god that's amazing
people build that stuff in mine
no that's not possible damn if pewds
punches water sheep again sven will kill
water sheep
don't punch watersheet
[Music]
wait you want to protect him why
if anything you want him to die to end
the suffering
oh god this became too dark moment of
horror your gift
that was people talk about the sunset
but that was equally intense in my
opinion
that was an insane episode normal
heartbeat disease heartbeat
heartbeat watching minecraft part nine
i knew there would be a lot of memes
about that sven get away
don't talk to him sven felix every time
he passes water sheep water sheep
i freaking hate water sheep can't wait
to build a torture chamber it's going to
be lit
brad inside whenever felix says what
that's not true
what you never played minecraft when
watersheep realizes
it can sell its bath water to gamers
oh my god no watersheet this is why i
hate him
this is a good example yeah alright i
know i i know i messed up
it really looked like it looked like i
wrote it don't give up
get another name tag it's already
happened thank you bros
thank you gamers jurgen and the boys 20
hours
plus zoom for details damn
okay look at this
in the bucket york is so cute
that is so cute too what a cow this is
awesome
i love water sheep so this is his true
character
you guys don't understand i hate worship
pewds be like why is water sheep free
lock him up
he's in the bucket he's safe i'm okay
with it
my dad had that enchantment curse of
vanishing
i don't know how appropriate the face is
as well well done
good meeting some people are saying to
make another goal with soul sand and
with their skulls
do not do disputes it spawns very very
very hard bots
called wither blah blah blah i don't
care you think i'm not a
minecraft do you think i don't know
about the water do you think you'll know
about that
i know everything about minecraft don't
even try to give me tips cringe
epic cringe yep you had one job this is
what i'm talking about
yep is a failure in everything
watersheep i mean
whatever his name is what you never play
timber simulator
oh that's amazing gaming month gaming
year
gaming live gaming existence
what felix thinks will happen if he
names his sheep
well can you blame me next meme when
everybody's talking about jurgen both
cow water sheep and sven
but you've been there since day one sad
photosynthesis noises no he's got the
honorable banner
it's minecraft month gamers i'll see you
in sven tomorrow legit
i was gonna record other stuff and i'm
like but i kind of want to just play
minecraft
let felix know you can add banners to
[ __ ] yes i've done this very epic how
felix will protect sven from now on okay
what is this
you have to let go of your weapons is
that so
now you can open all right
those are useless by the way no i think
this is more like
how you guys want sven to be protected
because if sven died serious is over
i've said it many times and you think
i'm not playing
because i ain't playing was that a lock
was that a pat pin code oh
good your crush her father her brother
her ex her crush you
imagine being water sheep not to be
racist or anything
but water sheep felix
runs out of dice uncovered
you run out of die you die that's just
the rules i don't make the rules
not water sheep watching
watching foods hurts men on accident
see i know it it's evil don't listen to
his mind tricks
history history of the world's tallest
skyscraper
okay 2019 ikea tower innovating
changing the game glory to the ikea
power
if ikea power dies we all die
water sheep in lego i built
nice well done this is
that's an up book that's enough but
right there can we just appreciate how
generally happy felix was when he found
someone well i thought it was gone
i thought i thought it was like a glitch
that he was barking or something
the only way to save smen when he
realized that jurgen one
returned a skeleton force no
stop feared subscribers when he hasn't
uploaded
minecraft in the last 48 hours you know
i gotta say i i really enjoyed
editing this 16 minute video full with
fine-tuned
cutting literally hours upon hours upon
hours of
uh gameplay cut down to a
beautiful perfection 16 minute video
for people to dislike it and ask for
minecraft videos
felix about to name watersheep yet
felix's name
yep yep i can't tell difference hell
sorry in swedish
felix should name his iron golems brad
all right they ran away but i'll make
new ones and i'll name them brad one and
two
and then i'll put chains on them and
then they can go in torture chamber with
watersheep
oh my god that's epic when pewds calls
you jurgen
multiple times instead of sven and
almost loses you angry noise
i'm sorry i was so stressed i couldn't
help it
sorry pewdiepie is now youtube's biggest
minecraft channel
facts and that's a fact
nine year olds after submitting a ton of
solution and seeing
felix use improvise
adapt overcome
oopsie
oh that's a good meme water sheep
firsthand come on
don't make fun of this horrific event
let's not it's not fun to joke about bad
events guys please
please that's that's so insensitive
think of sven think about how sven would
feel
empathy study google it gaming month
me a redstone engineer my respect for
beards
calm down i like how i held
i'm actually holding the whatever it's
called that's the
the giant she i don't know why you
always appeared time with soul sand
here's how you can easily save sven
what it didn't work i swear i swear it
didn't work
nobody guys in the morning this meme
wins this is the best meme
this is the best meme ever posted on the
subreddit congratulations
we finally found it zero depths damn
that looks slick dude
if i still had the tv i'd definitely put
it on it that's awesome
minecraft meme review what am i gonna do
minecraft meme edition i don't know if
this video gets 1 million likes we're
gonna make it
minecraft month maybe i said maybe maybe
if this video
you guys told me we're still worthy yeah
i'm willing to give this relationship a
second chance what we see
what the alexis hey how dare you
speak foul of ikea tower the greatest
tower oh my god that's amazing fan art
thank you very much zelma that's awesome
i could never replace him
but i'll do my best to make him happy
it was super awesome when i found out
that pewds used minecraft skin
i made in his videos so i made two more
oh my god
it's so epic can i get the sunglasses
still though
can i make it tiny requests thank you
can you make skins for jurgens then
to make them like look like they have an
armor everyone when felix tried to make
an iron golem with a jack-o-lantern but
it actually worked
didn't know that was possible gamers
teaching gamers i told you i'm a veteran
i know stuff dude
that's sick i love this that's so cute
this blonde meatball has no idea what's
coming see this
i told you it's evil stop him
save your hurricane please he's been
reborn reincarnated
in a slot machine please tell me please
tell me you shaved him
my tribute to the emotional roller
coaster that was my correct partner
when pete knew sight when pewdiepie has
been playing minecraft for nearly two
weeks
okay all right this is why i like
minecraft this is so easy it's all fun
like you can't say anything bad
what if watersheep has been building up
water
in his wool to one day unleash it to
bring revenge on felix
baba oh my god do you understand now
do you understand that he could destroy
everything i built everything i work for
he needs to be stopped
sven surviving the explosion is a sign
he he is protected by unknown forces
oh yeah he did survive that how lucky am
i there's also this other part no one's
talking about it and
it blew my mind because i saw one
comment pointing out okay so i got this
harpoon guy right he does three damage
come up coward look i have three health
oh god one
tank's jurgen he hit jurgen jurgen
tanked the damage so i didn't buy
and then right at that one missed i'm
done and then he hits the organ again
and then freaking spend time as the last
one
that was epic that's teamwork that's why
people are like oh he spends too much
time like
talking to pitch this is this is why i'm
a better minecrafter than
quick brad appreciation post for the
editing in pewdiepie's last migrant
video
i agree that was really good thanks brad
our own golems exist
pewdiepie hello stoneman am i stoned to
you you look like a stoneman
you have eyes like stoner you're a
stoneman
pewdiepie i just want to let you know
that i'm loving the minecraft let's play
please never stop
thank you mr peace arigato gozaimasu
should we build a mr
beast inside mr beast craft swedish
engineer creates first remote detonated
bomb
oh it was alfred nobel didn't he invent
the dynamite yeah yeah yeah yeah
we know sweet snow explosions what can i
say that's why i'm so good at minecraft
thank you swedish infiltrator
successfully destroys
an enemy military-based 1942 callerized
the time has changed it's literally
i've literally gone back to my roots
like this is the exact same thing
naming dumb things and just like
role-playing
but it's so much fun marzia you play too
much minecraft
i saw this like black block and i'm like
that's an enderman
this is like a pole or something i'm
like dude that looks just like enderman
society if we didn't make pewds sleep in
the nether yeah
how about you think about that before
you go to sleep at night my friend
called his new fold jurgen oh my god
here are some pictures oh my god he's
been reborn
you're gonna
all right i got it shut up edgar okay
i'm gonna end this episode here smash
like if you
enjoyed appreciate check out merch
support channel
thanks for all the support already
anyway and i see you gamers
that's right tomorrow every day baby
every day
subscribe epic bye what you never played
two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price